hi guys tim ferriss here wanted to talk
about cheat days so after writing the
4-hour body get a lot of questions about
cheat days do I still do them what are
the components of a successful cheat day
why do a cheat day and how do people
make mistakes or the most common
mistakes people make with cheat days let
me lay it all out so do I still do cheat
days yes I do I love cheat days a lot
bear claws would love ice cream I love
chocolate croissants the list goes on
these are all things that I really enjoy
and the purpose of cheat day is
multifold number one let's just say 90
out of a hundred people at least will
cheat on a diet so if you know you're
going to cheat you can limit the damage
by scheduling it in advance and this is
the purpose of a cheat day when you have
a cheat day this digs into one of the
mistakes if you will make that is one
wake cycle it is not 24 hours so it some
people like to do is they'll start at
say 8 or 9 p.m. one day and go until
9:00 10:00 p.m. the next day that is
going to increase the amount of fat you
store and the damage that you do so you
want to limit the consumption period in
other words from when you wake up to
when you go to sleep if it's one sleep
cycle all right so there's the
psychological benefit and the adherence
improvement what does this mean if
you're looking at a diet or you're
looking at any type of behavioral change
you're looking at say a method for
quitting smoking it doesn't matter any
type of behavioral change there are
really three I would say legs to the
stool and in order of importance in my
mind they are adherence are you actually
going to follow the program it doesn't
matter how good the program is if you
don't follow it so the good program that
you follow is better than the perfect
program that you don't this is where for
instance strict paleo and strict
veganism often fail and I get a lot of
flack from experts on the internet
experts very often who will say well you
should just have people go strict paleo
I can't believe you have beens people's
intestines are going to explode you
can't have them eat legumes
and then the vegans go crazy in their
own way and they say everybody should be
vegan and the issue there is strict
people on either side that I'm doing you
a favor because it is a Trojan horse the
slow carb diet is described in the
4-hour body gets more people to say
strict paleo than probably any direct
approach why because when I surveyed
more than intractable other 2000 people
think it was more than 2500 who followed
the slow carb diet more than 50 percent
said that it was the first diet they're
able to stick with consistently this is
the key so it doesn't matter if you're
strict paleo for a week and then go back
to eating hohos and and drinking double
gulps alright and the same for any diet
but if you are say even 80 percent or 90
percent to the letter with slow carb you
will see tremendous benefits and fat
loss and this is where if you look how
to lose if you look up on Search zigu go
how to lose a hundred pounds on this
low-carb diet you will see a number of
case studies and I've met dozens of
people who've lost a hundred two hundred
pounds alright and that is why even
though I experiment a lot with ketosis
alright so people ask me do you fall a
slow carb or ketogenic diet I generally
recommend slow carb I generally follow
slow carb because if you get it
primarily right you still see benefits
with ketosis if you are slightly off you
eat too many elements you eat slightly
too much of carbohydrate load and you
knock yourself out of ketosis all of a
sudden you're just eating an ape say 70%
fat diet with a high glucose level and
you're screwed
ok so it's a very binary now so we have
adherence are you gonna follow the
program number one I want to have the
highest compliance rate the highest
conversion rate in terms of behavioral
change for say every hundred people I
look at the percentage of people who are
going to follow it number one adherence
number two is it effective does it
produce the goals that you want or the
results that you want and then efficient
is it making use of resources in your
time in an efficient manner alright
cheat day limits the damage of cheating
which is inevitable for most people I'm
not talking about somebody who's won the
CrossFit Games five times those are
mutants sure they can they can eat say
sweet potatoes and chicken breasts and
lentils all day every day forever
because they're freaks yes the majority
of people not true all right
biochemically it is also very helpful at
least based on the data I have seen to
spike your caloric load say one big
bolus of carbohydrate and calorie
overload for a short period of time to
for instance
prevent your thyroid production from
down-regulating which if just by virtue
of selecting different food on the slow
carb diet if you are say sub maintenance
calories is very very helpful for
ensuring that you don't decrease your
rate of cellular metabolism and also
negatively affect hormone balance like
testosterone production okay this is
also why for instance if you're a
ketogenic diet nerd and you're trying to
gain muscle mass it's very helpful to
have a carbohydrate loading day and this
could be the anabolic diet from Morrow
DiPasquale
or Dan Dechaine had a similar diet their
number of different variations wherein
you are provoking an insulin response
once a week because it is an anabolic
hormone overdosing on insulin obviously
has its own issues but there are ways
that you can say be ketogenic for five
days Monday to Friday do a glycogen
depletion workout on Saturday and then
start force-feeding yourself with
carbohydrates that will be
preferentially stored as glycogen this
would mean very simple sugars I mean
glucose and so on you're not gonna want
to go for say fructose and things that
slow down that uptake but you can read
more about that some other time
but cheat days also biochemically the
point I'm making are beneficial and the
Third Point okay putting aside the
containing the damage putting aside the
biochemical reason if we're just looking
at adherence how do I get someone to
follow a slow carb diet
six months I do it by giving them a
cheat day so they don't follow a strict
strict strict diet for two weeks quit
and then have a cheat month this is why
people who've never lost weight before
lose 110 pounds or Ken and it's not
uncommon at all all right
what are some common mistakes so the
first one I already touched on one way
you can screw up a cheat day and make it
harder to recover from because very
typically let's just say if you're
choosing Saturday as your cheat day
which a lot of people call fatter day
then you will retain a lot of water for
the next few days and generally be back
to your Friday weight on say Tuesday and
then you will see the scale and a scale
is a blunt instrument I encourage you to
use say a DEXA scan or at least a
7-point skin caliper for tracking fat
loss and body composition not just a
scale it's a very blunt instrument but
if we're looking at the total your
weight cheat on on Saturday you retain a
bunch of water okay you get to about
Tuesday you get back to your Friday
weight and then for a few days you
continue to see a decrease which is a
decrease in body fat sometimes that is
masked because you're gaining muscle at
the same time this is very prevalent
with women who get frustrated is they're
not tracking body fat or body
composition they're tracking the scale
so this is a a meta problem that is
particularly an issue with women who
have been unfortunately brainwashed and
led to really focus on the scale but
you're gonna be gaining muscle because
generally you'll be consuming more
protein than with prior diets okay so
number one is we talked about limiting
it to a wake cycle all right number one
number two are you doing anything to
blunt your insulin or glucose response
and trust me it's gonna spike anyway but
are you doing anything to mitigate the
damage so the damage control chapter and
for our body very important one of the
things that I will very frequently do is
I will have a small healthy breakfast it
could be primarily vegetables it will
almost always have a decent amount of
fiber so it could be a small amount of
spinach
with a little bit of lentils you just
eat some lentils straight out of the can
or dal and chili doesn't really matter
but something that is going to blunt
your cortisol cortisol glucose and
insulin response then throughout the day
okay on top of that let's just say you
have caffeine plus a little bit of
grapefruit juice alright so I'm not
going to get into inner engine in and
how that interacts it's a component or a
compound within grapefruit juice and how
it interacts with coffee but suffice to
say you will be expelling let's say more
calories if you combine those two and
you also can use fructose this is the
sugar in fruit in small doses to help
blunt your again Lucas and insulin
spikes right this this will decrease the
amount of fat that you store and my prep
my preferred method here is freshly
squeezed grapefruit juice because it's
delicious a little bit of that say 1/2
cup or cup is cheat day so if you can go
crazy if you want and then have coffee
very shortly thereafter and then that's
what I'm gonna go nuts
alright so we have small meal which is
gonna be 5 or fiber heavy then you're
going to have caffeine it's and it's an
optional but it's a caffeine plus a
little bit of fructose if you're
following the 4-hour body prescription
you would also take pag during this
period so that is for the for the meals
before bed you're looking at alpha
lipoic acid garlic garlic which I
believe is Allison extract and then
green tea extract you're not gonna want
to take that before bed but you're going
to take those prior to meals to minimize
the damage other things that can be
helpful so we've talked about the basics
our berberine and I'll let you guys look
that up BER BER I and II bourbon very
very interesting and if you have if you
are talking to your medical doctor this
is only for use in console with a
medical doctor you can sometimes get
something called akribos which can also
minimize your glucose response to foods
of this type alright the B I would say
most common mistake
that people make aside from going
splitting in over two days is restraint
okay what does this mean this means you
say okay I'm going to cheat but I'm only
going to have a cheat and have one cheat
sandwich I'm gonna cheat but I'm gonna
cheat with rice and cheating clean can
be done and again there are mutants for
whom this is enough of a release valve
that that can keep them on the stricter
diet during the week for most folks if
you don't have a real cheat day meaning
eat whatever the hell you want drink
whatever the hell you want if you don't
do that you're going to cheat later in
the week why because you didn't scratch
that itch and in fact and I'm not saying
we're not aiming for bulimia or anything
like that here but I will deliberately
try to eat to the point where it makes
me a little uncomfortable a little sick
okay and I've gotten a lot of flack for
this too but trust me it works after
tracking and watching thousands and
thousands of people do this if you
half-assed cheat day you're gonna cheat
again and that defeats the whole purpose
all right so really go for the gold and
what you'll find is very often at the
end of cheat day you'll be dying to get
back to your regular slow carb diet your
clean diet and over time very often
naturally you will start to cut back on
cheat day but in the beginning phases
particularly when you're establishing
this habit this routine you want to go
for the golden cheat day all right you
don't have to you shouldn't actually
vomit you're not going for that okay so
there's a Thursday Goldilocks point but
it's like okay if I'm still hungry I'm
still jonesing for junk food amen
have another KitKat you know have
another croissant have another whatever
the hell it is that you're jonesing for
have some more ice cream and I really
don't half-ass it so if you see me on
cheat day every girl I've ever dated has
been disgusted by the display of
gluttony
there's witnessed on cheat day and I
love it so there we go the next mistake
that people make is thinking to
themselves well if one sleep cycle
is or one sleep cycle and then one wake
cycle is where I'm going to focus my
cheat day on why don't I just do that
twice a week so instead of doing say
8:00 a.m. to 8:00 p.m. I'm gonna do 8:00
a.m. to noon one day and then I'm gonna
do maybe half a day some other day
during the week this will almost always
from what I've observed lead to more fat
gain less progress then otherwise all
right so if it's cheat day cheat day
then you want to focus it within one
wake cycle I recommend Saturday for
social reasons because very often if you
make it say oh Wednesday could be a
Friday for some people then they'll go
out they'll have a bunch of booze on the
weekend and they'll end up eating pizza
or some other crap anyway all right
don't get to cheat days you get one
cheat day that is it now if your goal is
not primarily fat loss and is masking
and instead there are approaches and
this is more advanced so you want to get
a couple of months of slow Carm under
your belt first where you could follow
say a ketogenic diet or a slow carb diet
and then spike say for one meal on a
Wednesday with something like brown rice
and then again on Saturday okay but
unless you have say less than 10% body
fat not allowed to do that
generally Charles Pollock I would say if
you don't have penis skin on your abs
and not allowed to eat carbs after your
workout and you're certainly not allowed
to have to cheap is so crass as that is
pretty good guideline all right so
that's one and those are I would say the
most common mistakes that I've observed
in cheat days and there are those people
out there would say no cheat days crazy
you should have a cheat meal well is the
cheat meal gonna scratch the itch for
you in your heart of hearts well enough
so that you are not going to cheat at
all later in the week yes or no the
answer for most people is no all right
and whenever I get some diet guru or
self-proclaimed
leader of some cult who comes out to
attack me because it's low-carb legumes
oh my god lentils are gonna make your
head explode you're gonna give yourself
a lot of immune to sort of look there's
some people yes if you've already
already have a diagnosed issue with
these things probably shouldn't eat them
for the vast majority you're [ __ ] fine
okay and whenever someone gives you a
very strong opinion you should ask them
where are your data what evidence do you
have and at this point for our body came
out seven years ago
seven years of watching hundreds of
thousands of readers go through this and
I would encourage everybody to check out
the basics of this low-carb diet if you
haven't checked it out before I'm not
gonna get into it right now I can find
it for free just look up how to lose 100
pounds on the slow carb diet and it'll
pop right up with all the basic
guidelines and then if you really want
to get into the Nitty Gritty two
chapters in the 4-hour body that I would
recommend everybody check out our slow
carb diet chapter two which really gets
into some of the nitty-gritty details
and little things you can tweak that
make a big difference and then damage
control which is basically an expanded
version of how to minimize the fat gain
even if in some cases I kid you not
you could consume and I have consumed
say 10,000 plus calories in a day and
then clocked in with lower body fat a
few days later than prior to the cheat
day so how does that work well I already
give you some of the tools but for the
15 or 20 pages that really really get
into this I think it's around that it
could be shorter you can go to the
4-hour body and check it out so that's
where our body come all spelled out or
just go to Amazon or whatever other fine
book retailer you can check it out
hopefully that helps but cheat day I
still stand by it
sorry slow carb still stand by it
completely and hopefully those tips and
recommendations help you to a enjoy more
succeed more on whichever diet you
choose suffer less and gain less fat and
lose more fat
enjoy guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video I want to propose you
check out the podcast the Tim Ferriss
show why has it been number one on
iTunes across all categories in some
cases number one in business why does it
have 70 million plus downloads because I
interview world-class performers from
athletics business that includes
billionaires from everything imaginable
entertainment to tease out the routines
the habits the tools that you can use so
check it out
the Tim Ferriss show